which Democrat had a showing of the film
Birth of a Nation the movie of course
about the founding of the KKK I actually
do have the answer on this one oh boy oh
I don't what would that be what year
would that probably 19.
10 seconds I don't know Wilson
on this Face-Off we will find out which
modern day Gladiators know more about
the topic of the day corrupt Democrats
both past and present buckle up because
it's about to be The Rumble in the
Jungle baby the Jordan versus LeBron the
Joe Biden versus flight of stairs who
will win the ultimate showdown between
Nostradamus Michael Knowles and the
Hammer of the House of Representatives
Jim Jordan This is Face-Off corrupt
Democrat
foreign
how confident are you feeling today
after that intro not very confident
because if it's Jordan versus LeBron I
have the actual Jim Jordan himself here
I guess I'm Michael Michael LeBron James
I don't know obviously the congressman
has a lot of professional acquaintance
with a lot of corrupt Democrats this is
true and Congressman Jordan how did you
prepare for this showdown I walked in
and they they told me what was going on
what what am I doing they put this
whiteboard here on something I got an
eraser thing well here's what's gonna
happen I will read you both Clues you'll
have 30 seconds to write down your
answers and then we'll reveal it here's
the kicker though whoever wins will
enjoy a 30-second pitch from the loser
for either how great their podcast is or
for how fantastic they are as a
representative are you guys ready Ben if
I if I lose though am I going to fall
into some FEC violation you know
campaigning I don't know we'll we'll
talk to the lawyers after I'm always
happy to sing Congressman Jordan's
Praises no I think I think what he said
is if for some way I went somehow I win
this thing you got to run for Congress I
think that's what he's saying right now
now the stakes are very high
yo those on purpose now right all right
let's get into it this Democrat was
involved in the wiretapping of Martin
Luther King Jr which many say was
illegal now on the topic of Martin
Luther King this Democrat said about MLK
Jr that quote he's not a serious person
and if the country knew what we know
about King's ongoings he would be
finished and ironically this is the same
Democrat who gave an impromptu eulogy
after Dr King was assassinated who is
this Democrat
boy I have no idea I think I thought I
thought it was J Edgar Hoover that's
what I was going to say anyway I wrote I
just wrote down the Democrat the most
famous Democrat family in the 60s I just
wrote down that name go for it
the Kennedys Kennedy I said I said LBJ I
also was going to say yeah
it's actually the right it's actually
Robert Kennedy so I guess Carson Jordan
gets a point
yeah there's uh what's it what's up
someone once said the Kennedy's had a
great uh they had a lot of great lines
but one of them was um
talking about black people are in
politics sometimes that the Kennedy said
uh Politics the only game left were
grown-ups and I guess they were playing
it pretty seriously back then it looks
like for goodness sake fun fact on his
Wikipedia The Voice example for him is
actually the eulogy that he gave which
is pretty awesome Martin Luther King
dedicated his life to love and to
Justice
between fellow human beings
all right next up in 2006 this person
won Barbara Walters Most Fascinating
person of the year and was also an
honoree at the VH1 Trailblazer honors in
2019.
during what they declared as a National
Emergency this person encouraged strict
National rules for the country later
they broke their own rules after being
caught doing so they said it was quote a
setup and this Democrat allegedly is
linked to numerous insider trading
scandals and their daughters said of
them that they will quote cut your head
off and you won't even know you're
bleeding
who is this Democrat
Michael what do you have
Pelosi Congressman Jordan I bet the guy
had the cast in the freezer uh what was
his the Jefferson guy that we had to
cast and I'm sure I'm wrong on that one
we are all tied up at his Nancy Pelosi
oh thank goodness yeah good call yeah
remember the uh hairdresser Scandal
where they lock down the world and then
Nancy went and got like their hair blown
out I I made my guess on insider trading
oh yeah that's right that was but that
was covered that was 2020 right that was
yeah that was all covered yeah sometimes
Ben gets his dates a little confused no
2019 was bh1
okay yeah all right this Democrat
charged their City 12.5 million to build
a townhouse which was 20 times what it
actually cost they then fled to Spain to
avoid prison but were recognized by
locals and returned to the states and at
one time this Democrat was the third
largest landowner in all of New York
yeah what was it cost again 2.5 million
dollars and it was 20 times what it
actually cost to build that would now
get you like three minutes in a public
bathroom stall
get you a phone booth if there was still
a phone book right uh New York democrat
congrat congress can you give me another
hint I will say it was actually a former
state senator if that helps oh
I hate that that's like a forfeit I'm
gonna pick a random waspy name and just
hope it's a Democrat family in New York
Pierce that is incorrect it is Boss
Tweed oh really oh yeah well I should
have known that what was I thinking yeah
that's the most obvious name is tweed
daily now I get now I'm not I'm thinking
other cities Kansas City Chicago
thinking that if you're staying with
that theme Ben then I got a chance on
the next one maybe yeah okay all right
this one's actually in that same kind of
kind of vein all right here we go this
Democrat accepted a twenty thousand
dollar controversial pay raise while the
state that he was working for going
through was going through difficult
times and during his career they sold
liquor licenses and pardons and one of
those pardons was to the son of a
supporter who had been convicted of
killing his ex-wife and male companion
after failing to regain power this
Democrat was given a job as a private
Ford Automotive dealership worker and
fun fact this politician was what struck
in the neck by a stray bullet
oh this one is yeah this is the one
that's time you know when I first
started up when you when you started
down this road I I thought of
Blagojevich I thought he's this is
something with gregovic and the stuff I
don't know and it's going to get to the
stuff I do know but you never got to the
stuff I did know
Blagojevich for all of his many
sufferings I don't think he's got a
bullet in the neck so exactly I never
heard that this is back yeah I mean this
is a little older too I mean a 20 000
pay raise this is that controversial
yeah yeah that's right I will say just
to help you guys out this is a former
governor of Tennessee all right all
right what do you got Carson Jordan
I just put the Tennessee name down there
Gore what do you have Knowles I too just
picked a random Tennessee name uh Andrew
Jackson yes that might be it the answer
is Ray Blanton right oh like the bourbon
ah now that's something I would be
familiar with I don't know about this
politics and history but if we were
doing one about booze I think I'd be
pretty good yeah next question this
Democratic started 3 million from
companies that applied for Casino
licenses they were eventually found
guilty of 17 of 26 counts of corruption
including racketeering extortion money
laundry mail fraud and wiretapping they
have the seventh longest gubernatorial
tenure in post-constitutional U.S
history his third marriage was to a
prison pen pal and at the time of their
wedding he was 83 and she was 32 a
51-year age Gap what a Chad this is the
former Governor of Louisiana
I know you guys both know it when I say
it
yeah but I can't right I don't I don't
have it in 30 seconds oh yeah all right
what do you got Michael I got nothing
all right the nearest name with that age
yet that came to mind was George Soros
but his age Gap is only 43 years between
him and his wife and he has never been
the governor of Louisiana so this is
Edwin Edwards Edwin well I was not
thinking that who was before that who
was before Eddie Edwards it was um what
was that other big the name in uh in
like machine politics in Louisiana well
it may come up later so I don't know if
you want to give away your answer okay
yeah exactly exactly this is the hardest
episode we've ever played what happened
to the sports trivia yeah good grief man
we'll do it easier Gibson like the
double thing the 3-2 count hitting it
out of the park The Wanted bad in the
world series for the Dodgers I know that
kind of at least some of that I know the
worst part is that Mr Davey's over here
gets to look like the smart guy and we
look like a couple of Dunces but this
guy looked it all up
this topic was finding a Democrat that
wasn't and corrupt so I just picked from
all these random people you know right
now go to helixsleep.com Knowles with
everything going on in the world right
now you could really use a good night's
sleep that is why you gotta check out
Helix mattress he likes his harnessed
years of extensive mattress expertise to
bring their customers a truly elevated
sleep experience they just launched
their new Helix Elite the Helix Elite
collection includes six different
mattress models each tailored for
specific sleep positions and firmness
preferences I've had my Helix for about
three years now I absolutely adore this
bed night after night I sleep like a
sweet little baby I want the same for
you Helix has a sleep quiz that matches
your body type and sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress because why would
you buy a mattress that was made for
someone else why do you want to get into
my mattress huh I'm a married guy you
need to get your own mattress go to
Helix sleep.com take their two-minute
sleep quiz to find the perfect mattress
for your body and sleep type their
flexible payment plans make it so that a
great night's sleep is never far away
Alex offering twenty percent off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
my listeners hurry on over to
helixsleep.com Knowles with Helix better
sleep starts
now all right here's the next one in
addition to substantial allegations of
student loan fraud according to filings
this Democrats campaign contributed
nearly 80 percent of political payments
to their spouse's consulting firm and
that spouse is allegedly their own
sibling who is this Democrat
gentlemen tied up
after 20 Questions yeah yeah all right
this Democrat allegedly forced their
Congressional staff to perform chores at
their farm and houseboat they were
convicted of 10 felony counts including
bribery racketeering tax evasion and
after their expulsion this Democrat ran
as an independent candidate for another
term in the house while incarcerated he
eventually he actually received over 28
000 votes for 15 later David Duke posted
a letter written by this Democrat
stating that they were being targeted by
the United States Department of Justice
and more specifically being targeted by
the quote powerful Jewish lobby
with friends like that
that dad dad changed it for me because I
thought I knew that one but that was
like that
that crazy stuff changed it uh go with
your gut I guess the guy from Ohio gym
trafficking
I don't know if that's right or not
Michael I only because of the abusive
treatment of this person's staff members
I chose Amy Klobuchar
the sheriff from Ohio I should have I
should have been fair I should have told
Michael he's from Ohio I don't know if
that had helped or not but he was a
former sheriff and longtime member from
Eastern Youngstown area wow running from
outside a quick Side Story I'm giving a
speech and Suburban Youngstown probably
I don't know three years four years ago
I mean first they invite a Conservative
Republican to Western Ohio to come to
Eastern Ohio Youngstown used to be like
the most Democrat area on the planet uh
and I go there it's a republican dinner
and it's packed and like whoever heard
of like 500 Republicans in Greater
Youngstown you know it just wasn't and
it's because they're all Trump
Republicans and Jim traffickants
Widow and Grandson came up to me to get
a picture I mean that is how I mean I
know we're not supposed to get into too
much politics but that is how Trump has
changed Ohio that part along the river
you go from Pittsburgh to follow the
Ohio River to you know to the
Mississippi and that that swath is the
most pro-trump and it was like it
definitely has happened because I got
Mrs trafficking and and her grandson who
want a picture with the conservative guy
from The Other Side see it's those
anecdotes that I constantly try to
remind some of my pundit friends who are
just allergic to Trump they've got this
lifelong allergy to the man and they
just don't get it and they all fall into
the same kind of Beltway gobble to go
see guys you don't understand they're
they're actually are people in America
there are a lot of people who actually
like the guy and he's brought them over
to the conservative side the pundits
they don't they can't get it working
class people it's it's I mean I I know
we're not going to get in politics but
it's Trump won Ohio by eight and a half
points Ohio used to be the Bellwether
State you know 50 50. you want to buy
eight and a half points in 16 and 20.
and he wanted that because of of
Appalachia of the Southeast Ohio that
that portion of our state which used to
be the swing area yeah now it's it's
strongly Trump as goes Ohio so goes the
nation we hope fantastic Point number
eight under this person's administrative
watch the IRS and other federal agencies
were illegally used to Target and harass
the president's political enemies their
Administration oversaw the illegal sale
of arms to Mexican traffickers and those
guns have been allegedly used to murder
American law enforcement officers who is
this Democrat
if you have your answers
well it's yeah I got it
Obama Obama Obama there we go and we're
getting some easier ones now guys now
you're just yeah all right number nine
while not in the public eye this
Democrat went by the name Carlos Danger
when communicating with women around
town
wait let me bought that
this Democrat first got into hot water
after accidentally posting lewd photos
himself on Twitter it was published that
this Democrat had engaged in sexting
with a 15 year old girl from North
Carolina
who is this Democrat most aptly named
Democrat old nature that aren't unknown
to the
is i before e or E before I I said I
before E but I could have been making
that up okay uh yeah so I think we're I
think we're three and three or four
that's correct Anthony Weiner he uh he's
out of jail he's out of trouble however
he's still a registered sex offender for
life so there's you know some good stuff
there growing up in New York that guy
was supposed to be the mayor and then he
was going to be a senator Schumer called
him mini me because he he was this kind
of schumeresque figure but he was like
four foot ten and then
talking life comes at you fast it does
and so does this next question
this Democrat was convicted of perjury
and obstruction of justice in 2008 they
were released on probation after only 99
days and despite getting off so easy
they were still they still managed to
violate the probation and get sentenced
to five years in prison man I don't know
that one should I give you another
question take another clue all right
this is the former mayor of Detroit
huh oh I know I'm gonna get it then
every politician in Detroit went up in
jail at some point yeah it doesn't
narrow it down I'm just gonna guess a
common name I'm gonna guess
Johnson I don't know I have no idea all
right Knowles what do you have okay I'm
just gonna pick a random name and I hope
this is the right one Alfred
berlistowitz this would be a hard name
to guess this is Mr Kwame and Kilpatrick
former mayor
yeah now that you say it you actually
remember the story all right this
Democrat lost their 1992 re-election bid
to Thomas Barlow after becoming one of a
number of Representatives embroiled in
the rubber Gate House banking scandal
after he pled guilty to violations of
federal campaign Finance laws this
Democrat served two years in prison from
1995 to 1997. this politician ordered an
aid to destroy campaign records after
they were reported stolen following a
phony break-in at their Congressional
office strange fact at the last minute
this Democrat canceled a trip they had
organized and planned and accepted a
Kentucky speaking engagement the flight
they were supposed to be on was later
shot down by the Soviet Union killing
all passengers and crew what yeah who is
this Democrat
suspiciously I actually thought you were
describing a republican there for a
second uh the uh the the what was his
name Cunningham I thought that that
would have been a little later
um
1990. this Democrat was basically the
original that guy back there ain't real
plain person because they predicted this
and got off the plane before it got shot
down that's very real
perhaps too soon but that's that's a
pretty amazing story okay I think I've
got my answer I'll let I'll let uh I got
mine but I don't think it's right
Michael okay what does that say Dan
rostenkowski yes okay I wrote Whatever
Jim says
that's mine I don't know I don't think
mine's right the correct answer is Carol
Hubbard former Kentucky representative
all right next up as a member of the
Harvard board of directors this Democrat
decided there were too many Jewish
students at Harvard University and
helped Institute a quota to limit the
number of Jews admitted to Harvard this
Democrat appointed a former KKK member
to the Supreme Court and this Democrat
had several extramarital Affairs
including one with his wife's social
secretary in one famous interview his
wife was quoted describing their
marriage duties as quote an ordeal to be
endured who is this Democrat I think I
might know the tough one is it just
reminds you of every Democrat right
every time every clue 10 seconds you
just saw it you always think about just
like writing down Kennedy every time but
I don't think this is that's right
though certainly being married to him
would have been an ordeal to be endured
so the quote would certainly hold up
time
and I got nothing I said FDR
FDR is correct of course what was I
thinking former United States President
FDR yeah I figured he was early enough
that he if he wanted to appoint any
Democrats they'd that a lot of them
would be KKK and uh he was a Harvard guy
too A lot of them
it's just a numbers game at that point
you know of course I got to start
thinking like a little a little more
historical here that was that was
obviously that was FDR well this one's a
little more modern so this Democrat
referred to the disputed 2 000
presidential election results in Florida
as a quote coup d'etat this Democrat was
convicted on 18 of 22 corruption charges
ranging from mail fraud to filing false
federal tax returns and was released
from prison on April 22nd 2020 citing
Health concern their attorney argued
they were at increased risk of covid-19
because of their age and underlying
health conditions however in May 2022
they pled guilty to the charge of
interference with the IRS laws who is
this Democrat you know because the
Democrats never ever ever questioned an
election you know yeah exactly exactly
they've only every time a Republican's
been elected to Senate uh Century today
of deck you know but yeah it's always In
fairness though they never questioned
the elections that they win
yeah so uh
how many Democrats even know the phrase
coup d'etat
at least one yeah
at least one all right I get blank I'm
blank again dang that's pretty bad all
right Michael what do you got okay I
said Jacques chiroc because we use the
phrase coup d'etat that uh I don't think
he was quite a Democrat though I don't I
don't think so American the correct
answer is crane Brown serves member of
the United States House Representatives
in Florida wow oh yes she does all right
next up Time Magazine name this Democrat
one of the 50 most promising leaders in
the country and in 2002 he was named to
the politics PA list of best dressed
legislators noting his quote excellence
in Haberdashery he was later convicted
on 23 counts of racketeering fraud and
other corruption and and resigned two
days later this Democrat was set to
spend 10 years in prison however in 2020
they were mysteriously released from
federal prison after only serving about
a year who is this Democrat somebody
would a lot of style very promising a
lot of stuff
mysteriously released from prison it's
yeah it's kind of they didn't really say
why the release was so early I'm gonna
I'm just gonna guess time
I just guessed belgovic again yeah I
guess Blagojevich because
I don't know well
close this is
former United States
did you just sneeze what was that what
did you just say is that that might
pronounce that correctly I don't know I
didn't know that that's right yeah yep
20 counts of racketeering on with what
one year in prison that's pretty good
next up while this Democrat was indicted
for charges ranging from sexual assault
with a 16 year old campaign volunteer to
the solicitation of child pornography
this Democrat continued his campaign and
was re-elected without opposition this
Democrat initially denied the charges
which he claimed were quote racially
motivated this Democrat resigned in
October of 1995 after a jury convicted
them of sexual assault charges related
to sex with an underage campaign worker
and 16 counts of bank fraud on February
18 2014 this Democrat was arrested in
Zimbabwe for overstaying their visa
who is this Democrat I as soon as you
start I thought I knew it but I I don't
because I had someone else in mind and
quite a fall to go from elected American
official to getting arrested in Zimbabwe
wow all right what do you have I don't
have any I have nothing because I don't
I don't know I wrote Joseph Coney
because I remember that Meme and I
remember he was around Africa Tony 2012.
that's the one he was some sort of
warlord but I don't think he's the same
fellow that we're talking about here
nope this is Mel Reynolds former United
States Representative Mel Reynolds get
all All-American name melrel
it sticks out like a sore thumb in
Zimbabwe is the problem
all right next up this Democrats father
ran off with his half-sister when he was
nine years old the father also had an
affair and left with his wife's daughter
from a previous marriage yeah what this
Democrat was an FBI informant and they
also pled guilty to a misdemeanor for
failing to file a state income tax
return
who is this Democrat this is like this
is As the World Turns this is like a
soap opera what is that this what is the
the father absconded with his sister
with his half-sister half-sister when he
was nine years old okay I think I got it
oh then I'm gonna lose because I don't
have I have a clue here all right
Michael show I'm gonna say Ray Epps
close this was actually Al Sharpton
American Civil Rights Act no really no
yeah look that one up whoa oh my
goodness wow that's amazing his
background is even dodgier than I
thought it was look at the bright side
Michael you didn't lose and you don't
have to run for Congress this is a huge
relief wow we have one more question so
oh here we go what yeah we have one more
question
hi this is gonna be the old little tile
I got the pin back out okay all right
this democrat-headed amateur boxing
career that spans 13 months including
Golden Glove competition while Governor
this demo Brad tried to solicit money
for a vacant senate seat and allegedly
committed wire fraud ible
finally the last one oh here we go we
got that vodka I didn't write it all out
because you know what you know it's uh
I drew that beautiful hair pompadour on
the o here
that would be Rob Blagojevich the former
star of the lightning rod podcast
yeah and former governor of Illinois so
this is is this the first one that's
ended at a proper tie well we also had
Michael malice on famous dictators that
in a tie wow I do have a bonus question
to try to settle this yeah okay here we
go you know this man like runs the
country right you know this guy has like
actual jobs to do Beyond uh trivia here
I I I I do have to go pretty quick but
yeah I gotta say for the bonus question
because this is uh uh this kid like
decide who wins you know this is it
maybe you can win stuff okay we'll go
quickly what color was Monica Lewinsky's
dress oh come on that's an Ease on it
right that's Sarah yeah all right all
right well there's a there's a bonus
bonus question okay which Democrat had a
showing of the film Birth of a Nation
played at the White House this was also
the first ever movie showing at the
White House the movie of course about
the founding of the KKK I actually do
have the answer on this one oh boy I
don't because like what would that be
what year would that be probably 19. it
was important
10 seconds
I don't know Wilson
it is a proper tie gentlemen all right
uh I got within three seconds of beating
Congressman Jordan that I just guess the
Democrat then and I thought that's
probably that time frame I was with the
Democrat president
you think showing a KKK movie at the
White House is awful who's the most
awful president ever uh Woodrow Wilson
There we are very good
uh Congressman very well done thank you
for coming on I am so relieved that you
didn't at least totally trounce me we
can save it for uh part two when we have
questions that we may have we'll look
forward to it I do gotta run thank you
so much guys thank you Congressman well
there you have it if you haven't already
go get a copy of Jim Jordan's latest
book do what you said you would do
fighting for freedom in the swamp and
please write in the comments section and
let us know who you'd like to see and
what topic to cover in the next episode
of Face Off
[Music]
thank you